pasamos ahora al segmento de economía me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches ya lo decíamos
las protestas en China tienen su
repercusiones en los mercados
internacionales bueno Santiago hubo
caída en los principales mercados
bursátiles del mundo y también en el
mercado del petróleo los inversores se
debatieron entre el pesimismo por la
inastabilidad social en China y un poco
de optimismo para que Beijing acelere en
quitar estas restricciones las bolsas
chinas cerraron con pérdidas por las
noticias de las protestas otro mercado
afectado fue el del petróleo el barril
del brent cayó hasta los 80,97 dólares
una cifra que no se veía desde enero de
este año esto por el temor de una caída
en la demanda del petróleo mientras Si
vemos las acciones en esta las
estadounidenses terminaron con una
fuerte caída de ventas masivas de
acciones para Apple por las
preocupaciones sobre un golpe a la
producción del iPhone las acciones de
Apple cayeron 2,6% y pesaron sobre un
índice importante Ahí el esampi 500 en
el índice europeo stock 600 cayó como el
resto de los mercados mundiales por este
nerviosismo económico debido a la
sinuales protestas de China y en América
Latina las bolsas de la región tampoco
escaparon de esta mala racha Jorge usted
lo estaba mencionando Apple va a
enfrentar un enorme reto operativo a
raíz de estas protestas que están
teniendo lugar en China de qué se trata
bueno Esto principalmente porque como se
habrá se acerca la temporada navideña y
las manifestaciones ponen más presión a
las cadenas de suministro según
bloomberg el proveedor de Apple foxcom
producirá 6 millones de unidades de
iPhone menos de lo estimado ya que los
empleados de la planta del fabricante
concede en chenú fueron protagonistas de
estas protestas en contra del actual
política de China de 0 Kobe 19 los
trabajadores de la planta se quejan de
los estrictos cierres y de la falta de
suministros adecuados en Alimentación en
esta misma fábrica las protestas se
producen al mismo tiempo que los
ciudadanos de otras ciudades chinas se
manifiestan contra estas restri el gran
problema para Apple es que en las
instalaciones de chensui es donde se
produce la mayor parte de los modelos
del iPhone 14 pro y del iPhone 14 Pro
Max uno de los recién salidos y también
los que han tenido más demanda esto
haría que muchos que intenten pedir un
iPhone ahora probablemente tendrían que
esperar hasta enero del próximo año para
recibirlo Bueno yo por mi parte no
pienso cambiar el teléfono no entro en
esa lista Hablemos del Banco Central
europeo allí creen que la inflación en
la eurozona todavía no ha tocado techo
bueno por esto el banco pretende seguir
subiendo los tipos de interés para
contener el aumento de los precios Según
dijo la presidenta de la institución
Christine lagar lagar Indicó que los
tipos de interés seguirán siendo la
principal herramienta para llevar la
inflación al objetivo del 2% a medio
plazo en un contexto de ralentización
del crecimiento de la economía europea
en octubre para darte un ejemplo la
inflación en la zona Euro superó el 10%
anual escuchemos y que decía la
presidenta del Banco Central europeo
los tipos de interés son siguen Y
seguirán siendo la herramienta clave
para luchar contra la inflación unos
tipos de interés más altos reducen las
presiones de la demanda al encarecer los
préstamos y al influir en el gasto el
ahorro los préstamos y las inversiones
de los ciudadanos y las empresas Andrés
ejerce una presión a la baja sobre los
precios Aunque el ajuste tardará algún
tiempo en hacerse notar en la economía
Jorge hablemos ahora de la región de
América Latina en Argentina
restablecieron el dólar soja todo esto
con miras a captar Divisas bueno la idea
Busca que los empresarios aero
industriales liquiden sus exportaciones
a un tipo de cambio de 230 pesos
argentinos por unidad según la norma
publicada en el boletín oficial el
gobierno Busca recaudar un mínimo de 13
mil millones de dólares este dólar soya
tiene vigencia hasta el 30 de diciembre
Y es más lucrativo para los portadores
que
inicial que se cambia en 165 pesos por
unidad pero implica un anticipo de la
liquidación de Divisas del sector
agropecuario y también un incremento en
los pasivos no monetarios del Banco
Central argentino según el gobierno de
ese país el programa permitió en su
primera edición que se realizó en
septiembre pasado liquidar más de 8.000
millones de dólares y exportar casi 14
millones de toneladas de soya en menos
de un mes Argentina necesita recaudar
derechos exportación de soya y captar
Divisas para cumplir con las metas
fijadas con el fondo monetario
internacional a quien le debe más de 40
mil millones de dólares y continuamos
con las malas noticias en el mercado de
las criptomonedas Qué pasó ahora Jorge
Bueno tras la caída de ftx ahora otro
change que se llama blackfire se
convirtió en la última empresa del
sector en declararse en quiebra la
empresa concede en Nueva Jersey había
advertido a sus clientes hace más de dos
semanas que super suspenderían los
retiros y ahora los operadores tienen
que esperar el proceso de quiebra para
ver si pueden de alguna forma recuperar
algo de su dinero pero estos
procedimientos de insolvencia pueden
durar meses o incluso años y block Fight
tenía una importante exposición al resto
de empresas de Sam backman Freddy del
fundador de fts este esta empresa que
era la tercera más importante del mundo
de cripto activos Muchas gracias Jorge
por esta actualización es todo por el
momento en la economía aquí en directo
América a continuación el debate
[Música]